pour les experts on peut encore agir il
prend encore trop tard mais quelles sont
les solutions qu'il propose
mais parfois les solutions sont
draconiennes et commençons par etienne
le mentionnait la première cause c'est
la destruction des milieux alors une
grande partie du rapport le pour ce qui
est des solutions met l'accent sur le
système agroalimentaire la façon dont on
s'alimente l'agriculture par exemple un
tiers de la surface mondiale est
consacrée à l'agriculture trois quarts
de nos ressources en eau douce
par contre quand on regarde précisément
c'est seulement 9 % de ces perles qui en
fait pratiquer l'agriculture durable
alors ce que les experts disent qu'il
faut revoir ce système agroalimentaire
miser sur l'agroécologie qu'est ce que
c'est c'est produire en respectant
l'écologie de la technologie il y en a
il faut simplement avoir le courage de
nos ambitions c'est ce que plusieurs
experts disaient aujourd'hui alors
l'agroécologie ses bases et aussi sur
une meilleure gestion de l'eau mais
aussi il faut réformer la la chaîne
d'approvisionnement réduire le transport
excessif ça c'est au niveau macro sea
line mais il ya aussi des gestes qu'on
peut poser dans notre quotidien et notre
alimentation ça nous touche tous tous et
toutes
alors réduire par exemple la
consommation de viande on sait ça des
effets néfastes sur la santé sur la
biodiversité sur les changements
climatiques également augmenté donc
diversifier en fait notre alimentation
plus de végétaux aussi et réduire le
gaspillage alimentaire
une autre piste privilégiée qui a fait
ses preuves relance et la protection des
milieux
oui voilà la protection des milieux des
aires protégées la conservation aussi
donc investir en fait pour protéger des
espèces une donnée qui est encourageante
peut-être une des rares dans le rapport
c'est que par exemple les mammifères et
les oiseaux ont réduit en fait de 29%
leur risque d'extinction dans 109 pays
grâce à des investissements en dise
donc c'est une des données qui est
encourageant une des mesures qu on
devrait peut-être continuer préconisé
autre fait important dans leur rapport
les peuples autochtones on estime qu'un
quart de la surface est gérée opérés par
des peuples autochtones dans le monde
35% se trouve à être des aires protégées
et on note que la nature se dégradent
moins rapidement dans ces endroits là et
dans le rapport on insiste justement
pour inclure différents systèmes de
valeurs et d'intérêt on parle aussi
d'autres incitatifs les quotas de pêche
la restauration des écosystèmes quand on
parle de restauration ça peut aller de
simplement planté des arbres c'est
l'exemple le plus simple qu'on peut
avoir
alors beaucoup de solutions il y en a
des petits gestes qu'on peut poser mais
c'est certain que ça prend aussi l'aval
des gouvernements et de différents
paliers sa changement des mentalités
ça va prendre encore un peu de temps
merci jacques audrey à voir